jack reacher never go back as directed
by edward zwick and stars Tom Cruise and
Cobie Smulders and is the story of Jack
Reacher being falsely accused of a crime
he didn't commit which happens a lot if
you've ever read any of the Reacher
novels
this guy people don't like this guy so
him and Cobie Smulders character both
become fugitives of the law and they
have to figure out how to prove that
they are innocent as well as uncovering
a secret from Reacher's past that just
might have severe personal implications
I actually really enjoyed the first Jack
Reacher a lot of people were saying this
sequel wasn't necessarily warranted but
I really enjoyed that movie so I was
pumped to see this film along with the
fact that it's edward zwick and Tom
Cruise teaming together again because
the last movie they made was the Last
Samurai which I also find very
underrated so pros first Tom Cruise is
really good with the physical scenes the
action scenes these are things that
we've come to expect at this point he's
an actor who gives 110% when it comes to
physicality and his roles he's very good
with stunt work he really sells the idea
of this character being how he is in the
novels which by the way I actually have
read some of the Jack Reacher books and
I like this character and I like cruises
interpretation of him I think my biggest
positive in this movie is actually Cobie
Smulders she was really good as major
turner another person as I said who's
falsely accused she had a lot of
charisma to her
a lot of vitality she was a very fun
character and I liked her presence and
the camaraderie that she shared with
crews in this movie their back-and-forth
was fun to watch it was unconventional
it wasn't like smile and went to the
camera all the time these are two people
who don't really get along for a large
portion of the movie so saying that they
don't necessarily have the best
chemistry is accurate these characters
don't really get along for a long time
it's not like rush hour like we're Chris
Tucker and Jackie Chan don't get along
but it's funny these characters don't
really work well with one another until
they learn to and watching their
relationship evolve was something that I
appreciated in this film all that being
said I left the theater disappointed
because this is unfortunately a very
formulaic action movie that doesn't
really have anything remarkable about it
and what was very surprising to me was
that Edward Zwick approached the action
scenes in a very
ven tional way there isn't a single
sequence in this movie that I'm going to
really remember as that scene in the
first Jack Reacher film I think of that
amazing car chase well you got some
unbroken long tapes of crews doing a lot
of his own driving in fact all of it and
that was really exciting I think of the
chilling opening scene with the shooter
who was eyeing out his targets there are
a lot of scenes in Jack Reacher the
first one that I remember as being very
effective and really good there's
nothing like that and never go back
everything is just very conventionally
done it feels kind of like a
straight-to-dvd movie with a higher
budget with better actors one thing that
Tom Cruise has never been accused of is
not having charisma the guy always has a
lot of energy to him in his roles he
always is very likable and fun and he
gives a lot to his performances but I
got a say in this movie even he doesn't
seem like he wants to be here all I can
really think is that there was a major
miscommunication between director and
actor in this film because Tom Cruise
seems to be in a different place
sometimes than the movie wants him to be
sometimes they'll be this very slow
scene and then all of a sudden it just
cuts with this big blast of music and
they're running somewhere and you're
like oh we're an action scene all
of a sudden like what just happened it's
like the movie forgot to be an action
movie and then it remembers to be an
action movie but it doesn't really film
it in a way that feels like it's got
some energy or some power to it wick
utilizes a lot of very tight lenses a
lot of zooms you see things very up
close it's very Jason Bourne style with
less cuts the action in Jack Reacher or
Mission Impossible rogue nation which
are both directed by Christopher
McQuarrie was far better done it
disappointed me because there are so
many sequences were just like these
faceless goons come out of nowhere and
Jack Reacher asked to beat him up and
I'm like what does this have to do with
the story and that's my other big issue
with the movie this story is actually
very hard to follow not that it's
confusing it's just poorly told they
throw in the aspect that Reacher might
have a daughter but this daughter
character seems to have no purpose for
the story other than to get into trouble
and make the wrong moves to get them
found which was troublesome to me there
were so many missed opportunities in
this script and I got to say once you
get to a certain point in the
you wonder if anything that has happened
actually adds up anymore it's a story
that upon revision when you look at the
beginning the middle and the end and
then you look at things that happen
throughout the movie it just doesn't
hold up anymore once you learn certain
things Jack Reacher never go back is not
a terrible movie there's nothing
offensive about it you don't sit there
going like I hate my life as I watch
this if it came on TNT one day and it
was just sort of on I'm sure that it
would be entertaining enough to watch
it's just that it could have been a lot
better especially when you take the
first film and compare it to that and
the performers in this movie who are
normally amazing in films just kind of
come off contractually obligated I'm
gonna give Jack Reacher never go back
s-see I got to say this was a bit of a
blow this was something I was excited
for and I was one of the guys who was
really pulling for Jack Reacher I really
liked the first one but they really
dropped the ball here guys thank you so
much for watching please stay tuned this
Saturday I'm going to be releasing a
very cool video my wife and I worked on
our fourth annual Halloween special we
went to a cabin in Tennessee we filmed a
whole bunch of reviews revolving around
cabin in the woods horror films and we
filmed a short film that's interwoven
throughout all of those reviews that
proceeds throughout the video is going
to go up this Saturday I'm so excited to
share that with you guys we're very
proud of it and we've worked hard on it
and on Halloween day I have a special
surprise movie review for you that I've
wanted to do for quite some time guys
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh